pro-lifers are winning like never before
the abortion supporters are losing and
they are really really upset about it so
one of them has gone viral making a
video of all the ways that abortion
supporters need to argue with pro-lifers
offering lessons on tactics and
arguments that the pro-abortion people
should make i have not seen them because
these took place on tick-tock i am
constantly being kicked off of tick-tock
i never really used tik-tok to begin
with but then i say true things on
tick-tock and they ban me again because
xi jinping doesn't like it was that
beijing so anyway my producers have
found these videos they are by aaron i
don't know her last name a former nurse
a leftist she says she's a
deconstructing evangelical
whatever that is and she says her
pronouns are she and her pronouns in bio
that's always a marker that you're about
to get
just a really really great video this
wholesome american debunking is brought
to you by good ranchers i love good
ranchers more from them in just a second
first though here is arguing with
pro-lifers that now has 3.8 million
plays at this very moment take it away
aaron i'm gonna help you argue with
pro-lifers as a former pro-lifer myself
there are some things that they're going
to listen to that is going to fall on
deaf ears point one you need to focus on
the fact that pro-lifers legitimately
think abortion is murder that's true if
you tell them that oh you just support
you know unborn babies until they're
born you're not going to help them with
food and shelter that doesn't matter
because because it's murderers murder
right and also that point is not true
but yes murder is murder it doesn't
matter if they do that or not because
they still think that murdering that
child is worse than letting them
struggle and if you're going to talk
about the life of the mother versus the
life of the unborn child
you have to understand that statistics
are really in their favor because most
mothers most pregnant people do well
they will give you statistics like well
most people just aren't ready to be a
mom or they just can't afford it and
even if some people die in the process
of these laws rolling out
it they think that
overall you're saving more human lives
because the unborn are now surviving
she's
generally being somewhat fair to the
pro-lifers here and she's making the
point that
if you make a bunch of stupid
pro-abortion arguments the pro-lifers
are going to smack you down that's true
here she's kind of losing it a little
bit because one maternal mortality is
very very very low it doesn't mean that
there's no risk to pregnancy of course
there is risk to pregnancy there's also
risk to abortion women die from
abortions from legal abortions and
illegal abortions the year before roe v
wade was decided it was a very small
number but the the number of women who
died from illegal abortions was 39 the
number of women who died from legal
abortions was about 24 and when you look
at the states in which abortion was
legal or illegal the risk was roughly
about the same
so
obviously there's risk in any kind of
medical intervention and then she's
making a utilitarian argument she's
saying well the total number of people
who will be saved by pro-life laws
outweighs the total number of people who
will be killed by pro-life the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the few
that's not the argument pro-lifers are
not making utilitarian arguments or
consequentialist arguments we're making
arguments from the act itself we're
saying it is wrong to commit murder and
so it it is always wrong the action
itself is wrong yes pregnancy entails
risk just like abortion entails risk to
the woman but the way to judge the
action is not based on some gambling or
some odds placing or some some
abstract calculation the question is
should i kill an innocent little baby
and the answer is is no so she she's got
that one wrong there but generally she's
she's i think
giving relatively good advice for
arguments that are just not going to
work with pro-lifers because they're so
obviously bogus there's more from this
lady to get to in one second first
though you gotta go to goodranchers.com
knowles president ronald reagan famously
said all great change in america begins
at the dinner table we'll bring your
family to the dinner table with good
ranchers these guys are the best they
ship 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the united states right to
your door they age every cut to
perfection they give you the true
steakhouse experience right in your own
home the quality simply cannot be beat
when you subscribe i'm not joking your
price is locked in for life we're at a
time of crazy inflation going through
the roof and somehow you're going to
lock in your meat prices for life these
guys are wonderful i eat good ranchers
probably three times a week at this
point i love their products their
chicken their beef their burgers their
steaks all of it is so phenomenal use my
code noel's cannon wlas to get your
steakhouse experience for 30 bucks off
plus free shipping on your order
shipping is not cheap this is a lot of
top quality meat so take advantage of
this offer go to goodranchers.com
knowles these guys are the best start
bringing people back to the table and
eating seriously delicious food have you
already bought from good ranchers good
show me what you're making post a photo
of your meal tag me and my friends over
at goodranchers so they can see it too
all right back to this lady even if you
tell stories like uh you know fetuses
who like don't have a brain and they're
not gonna you know make it they see that
as kind of a you know a sacrifice a mom
can make and be like it's in god's hands
like
no physician should go in there and
abort something
um if it's still alive so that's also
not going to work but they if they don't
work in medicine they don't understand
the complications that carrying that
fetus to term is going to create so on
on all these geniuses you know who work
in medicine and they're such wonderful
experts and everything
very very often when doctors tell
mothers that their child is going to
have awful complications or is
are going to die at a very young age or
anything like this to impel them to get
an abortion very very often the majority
of the time
it's not true there i forget which
left-wing newspaper a left-wing
newspaper though prominent left-wing
newspaper ran an article about this just
within uh recent months which pointed
out that actually these false diagnoses
of terrible complications for the baby
are widespread actually the majority of
these sorts of things are
false and and so then you also come back
to the same old issue which is if the
baby is alive even if the baby might
have some disability even if the baby is
going to have suffering that is not an
argument to kill the baby any more than
you'd walk around and find a 15 year old
with mental problems and say well kill
that person oh he's got down syndrome
kill that person he's got a chromosomal
disorder yeah kill him he shouldn't live
that's a ghastly argument well it's a
gas the argument
when we're talking about a 30 year old
or a 15 year old or a 5 year old or a
little baby in the womb so with all that
said you have to focus on the fetuses
personhood
and i will post more about how you do
that to come of all of these videos from
the pro-abortion people hers i think is
the best i'm damning with faint praise a
little bit here but she's making the
point hey pro-abortion people most of
the arguments you're making are
unpersuasive now the reason they're
unpersuasive is because usually they're
just factually not correct but
also because they're philosophically
incoherent and she's she's saying yes if
you come at these arguments if you come
at pro-lifers from from the perspective
of shallow arguments that's not going to
work well sure manifestly that is not
true so far i only see about 30 percent
wrong 70
decent video i didn't i didn't go in
expecting to think that this
pro-abortion lady was going to be making
a video worth watching but generally
that's true if the pro-abortion people
stopped making such frivolous arguments
they would save their time and hours
[Music]
[Music]
you